[Music]
tired of living in mushrooms yep
sometimes I just jump low sick of an
overprotective
papa the Forbidden Forest is forbidden
you're grounded Hey Papa Smurf be bossy
mm-hmm then maybe it's time to try
something new I saw someone who looked
like that but if this means the lost
village is Anna legend if there really
are other Smurfs out there we need to
find them we're in this together
and by together I mean me and you and
those guys but mostly me and you what
don't be weird with April 7th
brainy clumsy well that's not even
convincing enter a secret world filled
with unimaginable beauty it's like a
workout for my eyeball satin beasts nope
eat all your acid every quarter
we're not in Smurf Village anymore
[Music]
hey have you ever seen something so
beautiful we've encountered a rare new
life-form there at times very
intimidating I'm really need to warn you
about the evil wizard Gargamel girls
protection move hey girl Smurfs mean
business
that's what I call talking out of your
butt
ah huh oh my Smurfs the lost village I'm
leader of the Smurfs I happen to be the
leader of this world boy whatever you
say Papa thing $8.00 nosy so what's
going on over there and there's one
thing they have in common 100 good old
dudes now for the one finger push up one
two